WITH FIVE DAYS UNTIL AT THE
TIME ELECTIONS, CANDIDATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY MAKE THEIR
FINAL PITCHES TO VOTERS, THE
ONES WHO HAVEN'T VOTED ALREADY
EARLY.
AMONG THOSE HITTING THE CHILL
FROM REPUBLICANS, GOP SENATOR
TOM COTTON OF ARKANSAS, WHO'S
BEEN CAMPAIGNING WITH DR.
MEHMET OZ IN PENNSYLVANIA AND
HERSCHEL WALKER IN GEORGIA,
J.D. VANCE IN OHIO.
SENATOR COTTON ALSO HAS A
BRAND-NEW BOOK CALLED ONLY THE
STRONG, REVERSING THE LEFT PLOT
TO SABOTAGE AMERICAN POWER.
HE GIVES HIS TAKE ON HOW
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTS ALL THE
WAY BACK TO WOODROW WILSON HAVE
BEEN STARING THE COUNTRY DOWN
THE WRONG PATH WHEN IT COMES TO
MILITARY AND FOREIGN POLICY
ISSUES.
HE WRITES, FOR EXAMPLE, QUOTE,
AMERICA'S RECENT DECLINE IS NOT
AN ACCIDENT, IT'S DECLINED BY
DESIGN FOR MORE THAN A CENTURY.
THE BILL DEMOCRATS APPLAUDED TO
SABOTAGE AMERICAN POWER.
THESE DEMOCRATS BELIEVE THAT
YOU CAN SEE A STRONG CONFIDENT
AMERICA BRINGS US --
SENATOR COTTON JOINS US NOW
HERE IN STUDIO.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE, GOOD
TO HAVE YOU HERE.
IT'S A POINTED BOOK.
IS THAT FAIR TO SAY, YOU THINK?
IT'S A POINTED BOOK?
>> I HAD A LOT TO GET OFF MY
CHEST.
>> IT'S VERY SHARP CRITICISM
ABOUT DEMOCRATS, AND I KNEW YOU
WERE VERY CONSERVATIVE, I DON'T
THINK I FULLY REALIZED HOW,
THIS CONTEMPT IN OKAY WHERE DO
YOU, HOW MUCH CONTEMPT YOU HAD
FOR THESE POLICIES.
I WONDER, DOES IT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT TO WORK WITH SENATE
DEMOCRATS GIVEN HOW STRONGLY
YOU FEEL THAT THEY STAND FOR
ALL THESE WRONG THINGS?
>> NO, NOT AT ALL.
YET THEY GO WITH SENATORS EVERY
DAY.
ONE DAY SUNDAY WILL BE YOUR
ADVERSARY, THE NEXT, YOUR ALLY.
THAT'S NOT AN ISSUE.
GOING BACK 100 YEARS WHICH WILL
SOON AS I OUTLINED, HE WAS THE
FIRST PRESIDENT TO OPENLY
REPEAT THE DECLARATION AND
CONSTITUTION --
UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS TRYING TO
SET THE COURSE FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> SEGREGATED TO, HE WAS A
HORRIBLE RACES.
THEN HE LIKE RESEGREGATE A?
>> THE LEFT CAN TAKE HIS NAME
OFF OF THE BUILDINGS BECAUSE OF
THAT, BUT THEY CAN TAKE HIS
IDEAS OUT THERE MOMENT.
YOU STILL SEE THAT TODAY
DOMESTICALLY, BUT YOU SEE IT
ABROAD AS WELL.
WHEN HE DECLARED WAR ON GERMANY
SHORTLY AFTER HIS REELECTION, I
WAS NOT FOR ANY OTHER GOOD
REASONS TO DECLARE WAR ON
GERMANY, THE FOUNDING FATHERS
DECIDED.
GERMANY CONSPIRING WITH MEXICO
TO SEIZE TERRITORY IN THE WEST
OR KILLING AMERICANS --
OR INTERRUPTING OUR ECONOMY
HERE IN AMERICA BECAUSE OF
UNRESTRICTED SUBMARINE WARFARE,
IT WAS ON BEHALF OF AFRICAN
IDEALS.
HE FAMOUSLY SAID, THAT WE WILL
MAKE THE WORLD SAFER FOR
DEMOCRACY, AND I WOULD SUGGEST
THAT THERE IS ONE WORD MISSING
FOR THAT, AND I THINK OUR
FOUNDERS WOULD HAVE SUGGESTED
THE --
>> AMERICAN?
>> WE SHOULD MAKE THE WORLD
SAFER FOR AMERICA'S DEMOCRACY.
>> IT'S A LOT OF POINT OF
CRITICISM THAT DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS DATING BACK TO
WILSON ALL THE WAY THROUGH TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN TODAY.
FDR AND TRUMAN WERE PRESIDENT
DURING THE ALLIES VICTORY IN
WORLD WAR II, OBAMA, OKED THE
MISSION TO GO KILL A SUM OF BIN
LADEN.
YOU SAID THAT TO CRITICIZE
BIDEN --
BUT YOU DON'T REALLY GIVE OBAMA
THE CREDIT, THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS --
>> THEY DON'T GET EVERYTHING
WRONG, OBVIOUSLY.
THE OLDER PRESIDENTS IN THE
20TH CENTURY ARE BETTER THAN
THE MORE RECENT ONES,
ESPECIALLY THE POST VIETNAM
PRESIDENTS.
EVEN WITH FDR AND TRUMAN, THEY
CUT THE DEFENSE BUDGET BADLY.
OUR ARMY WAS SMALLER THAN
PORTUGAL'S ARMY EVER TO.
>> THEN THEY CRANK IT BACK UP?
>> SAME THING FOR THE GREEN
WAR.
WE DEPLOYED OUR TROOPS INTO THE
KOREAN WAR WOEFULLY UNPREPARED
AND UNDER TRAINED, BUT REALLY
STARTING WITH JFK AND HIS
MISNOMER THAT JFK WAS A STRONG
PRESIDENT.
HE WAS A DISASTER AS A FOREIGN
POLICY PRESIDENT BUT THEN
ESPECIALLY AT THE VIETNAM WHEN
THE LEFT TURNED NOT JUST ON
AMERICA'S FOUNDING BUT ON
AMERICA ITSELF, THEN YOU BEGIN
TO SEE A STEADY EROSION OF
AMERICAN POWER THROUGHOUT
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENCIES OF
JIMMY CARTER, BILL CLINTON AND
ESPECIALLY BREAKUP ALMA.
>> ONE THING TO US INTERESTED
SINCE YOU BRING UP VIETNAM, I
WAS INTERESTED TO READ YOUR
CRITICISM OF THE NEW YORK TIMES
FOR PUBLISHING THE PENTAGON
PAPERS, WHICH WERE LEAKED TO
THE TIMES BY DANIEL ELLSBERG,
WHO THOUGHT THAT THE WAR WAS
NOT WINNABLE, AND THAT THE
LEADERS WERE HIDING THIS FROM
THE PUBLIC, AND THE PUBLIC HAD
A RIGHT TO KNOW.
YOU FIRST HAD TO BRING IT TO
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS, THEY DID
NOT WANT TO DO IT, SO THEN THEY
WENT TO THE PRESS.
HERE'S THE THING, YOU'RE ALSO
SO CRITICAL, AND I AM NOT
SAYING WRONG OF JFK AND LBJ AND
HOW THEY WAGED A WAR IN
VIETNAM.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH THE NEW YORK
TIMES BRINGING THE FAILURES OF
THESE DEMOCRATIC
ADMINISTRATIONS TO THEM, TO THE
PUBLIC, SO THAT THEY CAN SEE
WHAT WAS REALLY GOING ON?
YOU'RE A VETERAN, YOU KNOW HOW
MANY AMERICANS DIED IN VIETNAM
WHEN THE GENERALS DID NOT THINK
THE WAR WAS WINNABLE, BUT THEY
DID NOT HAVE THE GUTS TO TELL
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF OR TO
TELL THE COUNTRY.
>> IT JUST ANOTHER EXAMPLE OF
THE NEW YORK TIMES PUTTING
ITSELF IN A POSITION OF JUDGING
WHAT CLASSIFIED INFORMATION
SHOULD AND SHOULD NOT BE
REVEALED, WHICH IS NOT ITS
POSITION.
>> THE SUPREME COURT SIDED WITH
THEM.
>> THEY SAID THAT THE NEW YORK
TIMES CANNOT BE SUBJECTED TO A
PRIOR RESTRAINT.
THEY SAID THAT YOU COULD HAVE
CONSEQUENCES AT THE DEFECT.
>> DIDN'T THE PUBLIC AT THE
RIGHT TO KNOW ABOUT THESE
FEATHERS THAT YOU CRITICIZE?
US >> AT THE PENTAGON PAPERS
THEMSELVES, THERE WERE A LOT OF
REVELATIONS THERE.
A LOT OF IT WAS WELL KNOWN TO
THE PUBLIC.
IT DID NOT SHOW THAT THE WAR
WAS ON A ONE DOUBLE.
ONCE RESTRICTION BECAME
PRESIDENT, AND HE TOOK THE
HANDCUFFS OFF OF OUR MOTOR, WE
IN EFFECT HAD THE WAR WON BY
1973.
WE HAD STABILIZED THE
SITUATION.
THE VEHICLE THEM HAVE BEEN
DESTROYED AS A FIGHTING COURSE.
HO CHI MINH'S ARMY HAD NO
LONGER --
IT WAS ONLY WHEN HE WAS
WEAKENED BY WATERGATE,
DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSMAN BEGAN TO
CUT FUNDING, INCLUDING A YOUNG
SENATOR JOE BIDEN, THAT WE HAVE
AN ABSOLUTE DISASTER IN SOUTH
VIETNAM, WHEN WE HAD
HELICOPTERS LIFTING OFF OUR
EMBASSY THERE IN 1975.
>> ON THAT SUBJECT, YOU
COMPARED THAT TO THE BOX
WITHDRAWAL FROM AFGHANISTAN
UNDER THE BIDEN MINISTRATION.
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOMETHING THAT A FELLOW VETERAN
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN ADAM
KINZINGER TWEETED.
HE SAID, I BLAME BOTH TRUMP IN
THE MOMENT COMING IN AND BIDEN
FOR THE BOTCHED ENDING.
I'M NOT PICKING SIDES BECAUSE
BOTH SIDES HAD FAILED TO.
IT'S THE TRUTH ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
DO YOU HOLD PRESIDENT TRUMP
ACCOUNTABLE AT ALL FOR THAT
PEACE TREATY THAT HE AND
SECRETARY POMPEO NEGOTIATED
WITH THE TALIBAN, WHICH BIDEN
INHERITED ANY MIGHT REMEMBER,
TRUMP WANTED TO HAVE TO TALIBAN
LEADERS COME TO CAMP DAVID NEAR
THE ANNIVERSARY OF 9/11?
>> IT'S PRESIDENT BIDEN WHO IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT HAPPENED
LAST YEAR IN AFGHANISTAN.
AS I WRITE, THAT AGREEMENT WAS
NOT WITHOUT FLAW, BUT IT WAS
BASED ON CONDITIONS ON THE
GROUND THAT THE TALIBAN WAS NOT
MEETING IN 2021.
I THINK A LOT OF WHAT HAPPENED
IN 2021 IS THAT JOE BIDEN HAD A
CHIP ON HIS SHOULDER GOING BACK
TO 2009, THAT BARACK OBAMA HAD
SIDED WITH MILITARY ADVISERS
LIKE STANLEY KRYSTAL AND THEY
BITTERNESS AND ADD A TRIP TO
AFGHANISTAN.
>> AND BOB --
GATES >> ILLEGAL IN AND
EVERYONE ELSE, JOE BIDEN WAS
THE ONE PERSON IN 2009 WHO KEPT
POISONING THE WELL BETWEEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA AND SENIOR
MILITARY LEADERS SAYING YOU
HAVE TO GET OUT, YOU CAN'T DO
THIS.
HE >> HE THOUGHT THE GENERALS
ARE JAMMING HIM.
>> HE WANTED TO PROVE THAT HE
WAS RIGHT.
WE HAD NUMEROUS INSTANCES OF
TESTIMONY AT THE COLLAPSE OF
AFGHANISTAN LAST YEAR OF
SECRETARY AUSTIN AND GENERAL
MILLEY AND GENERAL MACKENZIE
AND OTHERS SAYING THAT THEIR
BEST ADVICE IS THAT THEY WOULD
KEEP A SMALL CONTINGENT IN
AFGHANISTAN, THAT WE KEEP
CIVILIAN CONTRACTORS THAT TO
KEEP THE AFGHAN AIR FORCE
FLYING, SO THAT THEY CAN
PROVIDE AIR COVER FOR THE
AFGHAN TROOPS.
EVEN MOST OF THE ADVISERS, MY
UNDERSTANDING IS IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AND STATE DEPARTMENT,
ADVISED JOE BIDEN --
>> BUT YOU DON'T HOLD TRUMP
RESPONSIBLE FOR IT.
YOU SAY IT'S A FLAWED TREATY?
>> IN THE END, IT WAS JOE
BIDEN'S DECISION AS COMMANDER
IN CHIEF LAST YEAR.
>> FIRST OF ALL, THIS
UNDERLINES WHY HE SHOULD BE
COMING ON CNN MORE, SO THAT WE
CAN HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS
BECAUSE IT'S GOOD TO --
NOT JUST ON FOX OR IN ARKANSAS.
I KNOW THAT YOU WILL NOT
ANNOUNCE MUCH OF THAT YOU'RE
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT IN 2024,
BUT TWO QUICK QUESTIONS.
DOES TRUMP'S DECISION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT HE RUN, WILL PUT
UP ANY ROLE IN WHETHER YOU
DECIDE, AND YOU THINK YOU'LL
MAKE A GOOD PRESIDENT?
>> I'LL JUST SAY TWO THINGS,
FIRST, WE HAVE AN ELECTION FIVE
DAYS FROM NOW, AND THAT'S WHERE
MY FOCUS IS.
THERE WILL BE A TIME OUT THE
ELECTION TO THINK ABOUT THE
2024 ELECTION, BUT ANYONE WHO
THINKS THAT THEY CAN BE
PRESIDENT AND WANTS TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT SHOULD CHECK OUT A
COPY OF ONLY TO STRONG SO THAT
THEY CAN LEARN HOW TO RESTORE
AMERICAN POWER.
>> Y